[Music]
The demonstration, why should we say to racism? Tell
fascism, why should we say that Tunisia is an African state and heritage?
Welcome to all groups.
[Music] For the
first time in the history of contemporary Tunisia, a president of the
republic makes a speech about class, and it includes violence
and discrimination on the basis of color, race, and nationality. The
first time in the history of Tunisia
against Tunisian society.
Outside, I'm afraid
[Music]
In attempts to borrow from homes with the ban,
even this,
I'm a racist in the future, even
[Music]
If I knew that my country would receive me, I would be
arrested and troubled because I am against the
injustices that happen, I would go out
[Music]